hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to magicite a game those
kick-started a while back and it's been
updating itself on Steam and early
access it's a roguelike game with
permanent death that features mining and
crafting and all that sort of stuff but
that's besides the point
I'm freaking adorable lucky that to
remind me of Castle Crashers in a way
but either way I'm gonna get into it it
features permanent death oh you know I'm
gonna do well there's also like Oh God
am I gonna die already don't know don't
know no no no no you don't come nary a
big bug ant huh oh god why won't you die
woah God why Arctic ray we did it we
survived
instead of bpe hello mister oink-oink
I'm gonna steal your meat for my flesh
I'm gonna feel alright your meat thank
you very much so there's a lot of charm
into the game like this awfully minimum
Italy don't even think about it boar
whatever you're a bear boar you're a
bear Pig are you a man bear pig you
better back off and that's crafting it
all dude uh I don't want to die yet you
stay away from me I got a shroom back
off and I got an axe now what is landing
on top of it hurt what is this not Mario
give me give me give me come on if I
could trap it under that thing it would
die very is I die okay no huh come on
got a chop to piss out of you stop
moving around let me kill you I got
dingus David I okay this is not going
well okay I'm dead way to go
good job man bear pig you made a fool of
me a fool you you made a fool of
everyone watching out there and now
everyone's gonna be upset with me and
not you so suck it okay so that did not
go very well I ran into a lot of enemies
very early on I was hoping to be able to
survive a bit of longer than now okay
good
y'all it's everyone's just gonna dick
with me okay let me just get into the
crafting side of things because it's
very in-depth game and I don't want to
be bothered with anything else so I'm
gonna I'm gonna go fight that guy I'm
gonna kill him I don't get his goop cuz
he's obviously a goopy man and then I'm
gonna steal his group and use it to
craft up more goop and then I'm gonna go
eat those piggies in case I take any
tablet from Oh God not you again you
stay away from me you sassy Beast nope
oh you kill them
you don't kill them what's the point I
thought this is gonna be cooperation
you're such airholes I need to do
something else
herb Adobe yeah that's right are you
scared now oh you're all scared of me
I'm a man on the edge I'm a man with an
axe a man with a plan
actually I don't have a plan but that's
besides I might my plan is to kill you
cuz you've done me wrong you've done me
much wrong see I'm gonna go up here
I forgot that I could double jump
actually I only recently learned that I
could double jump like a minute ago so
I'm gonna actually okay so I'm gonna
stay away from that guy until I can
craft up something worth crafting oh I
got a dodge mechanic so either way we're
how do I get to my crafting how do i
craft how do i craft ooh I got a wooden
plank that's that's good wouldn't blade
that's good ah oh come on that's just
another axe got dingus damn it whoo
there we go
yeah I got a sward that's all I need for
now that's all I care about I'm gonna go
kill some boosters because I am very
very vengeful and I don't care much for
any of your sass cover Oh what are you
doing you're not supposed to give me
sass I'm supposed to give you sass come
back here you [ __ ] ah he's gonna get me
Oh God
here's abouts Kelly oh god I'm gonna die
I don't want to die again I just crashed
in a squad
give me your me meet me what's your meat
in my mouth come on come on come on yeah
oh god don't do that unpredictable
behavior I do not like that okay yeah I
did it I seen it everybody pray for me
whoo okay you got a shift-click items to
make him do stuff
cactus not what I wanted oh god why did
I make so many oh that does not help me
okay well crap I got a bunch of sward
hilts oh okay now we got to figured out
I had to figure out how to actually use
the potion so I got a lot of stuff in my
inventory but I need more so I'm gonna
need to go get more supplies I need to
find out how to make a pic cuz once I
find out how to make a pic I'm in it to
win it
okay so I'm starting to get the
it's game like most games I don't go
into it with any prior no is that a PE
well got another B's yeah come on yo
that's I'm gonna chop wood and chop you
at the same time also apparently I
leveled up okay so that's broken that's
fun
hey come at me bro I'm a man on the edge
ah yeah that's right yeah you don't want
to mess with me you better back off
what are those things what are those
Viney things ow
yeah yeah come here I want that piggy
piggy huh okay that didn't work no no no
no no piggy get out of the way I'm busy
yeah I'm a BA there we go
I'm a busy busy busy bee dangit lesser
come on stride can I do that nothing
that's awesome oh that's the best
chopping wood chopping wood need to chop
some wood into ladder come on come on
huh huh huh it's our to open the
inventory by the way give me a moment
you didn't think [ __ ] roughage okay I
keep making swore delts I don't need
sward hilts and he does I need to make
up yeah ah oh I remember you you still
want a piece of me I'm violent in many
ways and now you're dead thank you
so how do I make something to mine this
rock up I need to be able to get the
rock uh yeah okay whatever oh god don't
Kelly oh god don't kill me don't kill me
don't kill me
hey you better back off I'm a man on the
edge and I don't want to die God there
are a lot of beasty beasts out here why
so many bye Betty
I'm also apparently going through
puberty please get out of my way I'm
trying to survive here in this charming
charming world by the way this game is
actually really cool I like this a lot
there's a lot to love about this game no
you back off I don't wanna mess with you
and you don't wanna mess move
was aborted gold am I ever gonna reach a
vendor or am I just gonna gather up
materials until I'm just supposed to die
over and over again I lose everything
what I die but you want some of me I
know I'm starving
watch me eat this I just pooped why okay
that is the grossest thing I've ever
seen and somehow it makes this game even
more charming so good job dot you fairy
bastards oh no I wouldn't Acts is about
to break I'm too worried hey what's this
over here hey I found something
what are these oh cool all right
I love to Flora the tailor I ain't got
nothing for you I'm out here how about
the blacksmith I want that I need that
give me that give me the back can I have
the bat can I have that how do I get rid
of God dingus damn it get out of my face
it's dangerous Yolo and buy something
this one that's the idea that's what I'm
doing
oh those guy there's a guy I can sell my
treasures up there so that means that I
can get rid of stuff that I have here
all that is nice thank you these useless
sword hilts that I have thank you for
clearing out my inventory I'm not gonna
get rid of this potentially useful stuff
but hopefully that's gonna help out a
little bit so now I can go down there I
can get that pickaxe there's actually a
nicer pickaxe nail that was it look at
that yes yes yes I'm doing it I am doing
it to everybody can you believe it I'm
actually doing it not doing it that well
but I don't know how to get anything
else besides the wooden pick I don't
have the wouldn't pick is only available
in the store or if I can eventually
crafted myself okay that doesn't work
they're carrying on it is a beautiful
blue glow down here you can hurt me what
are you yeah I don't I don't come back
any masks blue boy yeah
I warned you I warned you all huh okay
that broke right away good need to make
another no pirate II got one man yeah
yeah see ya I'm gonna kill ya see you
slug got my raw meat here yeah hey why
are you blocking that or I need that for
stuffing things hi Becca thank you thank
you very much
I'm gonna use my wooden one first well
UNK [ __ ] I I got a stone is that good I
have no idea I feel like I'm playing a
game and everyone's gonna be judging me
harshly you're not judging me harshly
out there are you you wouldn't do that
to me before you love me ah jump out of
the way come on I'm gonna kill you but
first I'm gonna mine up this thing I'm
gonna use the wooden one
monkeys how are you doing yeah my god no
no no aah no oh man come on
finally Caen oh I was doing so well you
sons of [ __ ] now you decide to hurt me
why are you gonna hurt me so much what
have I ever done to you I thought you
loved me
there's a waiver Bay god dammit stop
hitting me I'm trying to live living is
what I'm trying to do maybe I had some
health potions and I didn't actually do
anything with them that is always a
possibility with me I I would never
underestimate the ability for me to make
a stupid decision I'm gonna go this way
screw you screw you and all you do I'm
gonna go over here this way and go to
hell I'm a tree-cutting master and my ex
just broke need to make another one
don't you think you're gonna run away
from me piggy okay you're dead never
mind I was gonna go on this long spiel
about how I was gonna die and your life
and the fate was to destroy you and you
just didn't let me finish which was
awfully rude back yeah why don't you
come out from the oh god what is that oh
I did I want to know what that is it is
big and he is glowing and he is Chomp
Chomp II I'm gonna call you chump II and
I must stay the hell away from wherever
you are
there's no way then I'm skilled enough
to defeat all of you so I'm just okay
I'm gonna fall down first and then I'm
gonna go up here goodbye everybody
forever and ever and ever and ever and
ever and ever and ever a bear herd if
what that's good for me I'm glad I ate
all that raw meat oh my god what is that
what are you come on your secrets huh
giving them up give up eyes bees it's
the secret is bees I'm dead why does the
secret have to be
please Oh Oh goddamnit
whoa I got something ha ha oh oh oh one
more try
what are you fairies all about why do I
need you can I bottle you up and then
drink you later that sounded much more
gross than I wanted it to be yeah get
out of here these are my trees just
because you're running away from me in
horror doesn't mean that I'm gonna let
you live
I am the merciless markiplier Oh magic
ray sight ok Liars a la tuya I'm gonna
go up here now I'm gonna go over here
where you're not and then you can't kill
me so goodbye forever and ever and ever
and ever and ever and ever and ever and
ever and ever
ok I got a sworn now ho sick moves bruh
thanks me I know I'm great come here oh
oh oh what now huh oh that hurt ok what
now ow why why why why do you do this
that's right why are you dead because I
killed you that's why in case it wasn't
very obvious yep
thank you for dying quickly and evilly
not evilly but easily you're the same
thing hello
you want to die prepare ok good thing
you die there because I would have been
very angry if you came all the way over
here nope get my health back still Oh
know how to craft up a pickaxe I've
tried every combination I think that you
may have to buy actually buy them ooh I
got a pick handle oh my god oh my god oh
my god oh my god oh my god oh my god oh
my god Abbi yeah yeah oh my god yeah I
can't believe that took me so long why
didn't I think I could do that I'm such
an idiot all you guys are probably
yelling at me is so mad but you guys
wouldn't be mad at me right this is a
little I'm just youtuber I'll try to
make you guys that voted me entertaining
baby yell at me
Sorry Sorry ah marry me I'm picking
things with my pickaxe and not my nose
thank you
what are you doing cowering over in the
corner doing oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh
is that how it's gonna wait what what
how did I cook those what the hell just
happened oh no what happened
yeah I'm not hungry anymore
I don't do thee no longer yeah yeah
thank you David think about you suck my
poopy come here oh I'm gonna turn your
are you after I eat you into poop huh ah
right I'm too skilled yes oh he didn't
give me any meat oh that's what she said
she was said okay doing much better on
the whole uh getting not dead thing yeah
yeah got guy yeah yeah yeah yeah get out
of here
whoa select a skill path I don't know
what that means
um no I just wanted to look but I got a
chargeability I don't know what that
means
oh hey chargin brethren of my friends
did I mention that this game is also
multiplayer this game is really really
fun I can already say that I recommend
it because there's a lot more to it than
what I'm doing which is not showing very
much but trust you me you can be good at
this game unlike me and you can play it
and have a lot of fun I'm actually
barely gonna played in the past so
creeped it ah you get out here I just
want my stone hi ha you came back
no I will not die again I can't I jump
very high
know about this no no out that's guys
you think you and me excusably the end
for me bite abattoir Omar this is not
the end for me
you're all gonna say I'm a man with a
plan and I'm not gonna die as easily as
you think I am today really doughnut
I've come so far I've learned so much
isn't that Gilly okay I just got a
challenge that dude down there and uh
can I eat this I yield one point and i
made a poopy poop good for me come here
come here come here
yeah why you don't even think about it
I'm a man on the edge are you think
you're defended by that spiky block I'm
far too smart how damn it hit you far
too smart to be defeated by steps such
things as that okay my axe is about to
break you got my pickaxe well no you
don't thank y'all whoa whoa too close
thank you all right I'm gonna go in the
first one this time
just give me to a shop yes it do so what
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna sell my dudes
to the dude and you come here okay
um once again I have no idea what I'm
doing so I'm kind of at a loss but
that's okay cuz I'm gonna get this and I
don't know what it is but it looked cool
and how about that everybody that is
what matters that is what matters here
everybody keep that in mind it's not
about it's not about uh it's not always
about winning not always about winning
sometimes it's about being cool cuz
being cool is pretty much the coolest
thing you can possibly do let's be
honest here here don't you complain
about being dead lots of people of an
owl like me might be dead do not know
god damn it why I was going to do it
I've only got one else now we are God
not you you back okay I'm gonna take you
on I got my fancy new sward what you
gonna do huh you're slow yeah slow yeah
that's right yeah back off I'm whoa what
the hell is that
why oh goodness gravy why why oh my god
no oh oh oh one life go to go the
distance
gonna go God let it go the distance guys
I
go the distance oh well oh I got a Nobel
thingy cool
I got a peon very cool alright so anyway
that was magicite there's a lot more to
this game than you've seen this was a
lot of fun hope you enjoyed me playing
it if you liked this game please click
the like button down below let me know
in the comments and if you have
recommendations for more cool games like
this because I'm always on the lookout
for great games like this let me know in
the comments below yeah check out the
annotations more videos that I've done
of cool games and basses all big players
blah blah blah either way thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye
mr. boy okay
can't be bothered do you see this room